- [Whitney] My name is Whitney,
and I live in Eminence, Kentucky.
I live with my mom and
my two younger siblings.
I go to school at Eminence Independent
and Bellarmine University.
I've always had a thing for anatomy.
- [Buddy Berry] Whitney's
a special young lady,
and our early college
program has been her vehicle
to see the potential of her future.
The Eminence spirit is
to keep looking forward.
What drives us is giving kids the freedom
and the empowerment to do
whatever they put their minds to.
We want to give them
opportunities and experiences
that would far exceed anything
that any generation of Eminence
student had ever had before.
We felt like we were
having students graduate
academically prepared to go
to post-secondary education,
but kids would go, they would spend
maybe a semester, maybe two, and then
all of a sudden they're back
in town, they didn't complete.
- We were having huge drop-out rates,
and so we needed to do something.
- [Thom Coffee] Dr. Barry and
I called Bellarmine University
and said, we have a crazy idea
we'd like to pitch to you.
- [Buddy Berry] And with one yes,
the Bellarmine-Eminence
partnership was born.
250 kids have gone through it,
and 249 are still in college.
- So this was an opportunity
in a relatively safe environment
to get them thinking about college,
what college is like, what
college-level work is like,
and let those students
explore a little bit
rather than just throwing
them in the deep end.
College, especially if
you come from a family
that has no college
experience, it's very daunting.
- I didn't go to college,
so I think it's done good for Whitney.
She's always been a go-getter,
and she wants to be a neurosurgeon.
- My mom's been supportive,
but it's a little difficult
because she doesn't
know how to help me out,
so I've had to turn to my
teachers and my counselor.
- And so I want to make sure that you know
what courses to look for next year.
Sometimes it's as simple as, I just need
somebody to tell me not to give up.
They can do the work,
they're capable students,
but they need the support network.
- One barrier that we found was,
a lot of these homes didn't
have internet service.
And so, we created a WiFi school bus.
- [Whitney] And honestly, it's amazing.
Say I wrote a paper the night before,
I forgot to make corrections on it,
I can use that WiFi
while I'm going to school
and then send it on its way.
- [Graham Ellis] In their
first year, they take
Bellarmine courses from
our Bellarmine faculty,
but just for the Eminence students.
- We took English 100,
a Human Geography class,
and a Speech class.
It was kinda rocky at first,
I didn't raise my hand or anything.
If I didn't understand
anything I just went home
and tried to figure it out myself.
But in college, you have to
ask your professor questions
or they're just going to move on
and you're going to be so lost.
This year is my second year in.
Honestly, it was more comfortable.
I felt like I knew what I was supposed to.
I have a question.
- So, epiphyses are the ends of the bone,
and diaphysis is the shaft, the...
- My second year, I actually
got to choose my classes
after finishing my GenEd
courses my first year.
I chose Anatomy and Physiology,
and then I also chose
Western World History.
- [Thom Coffee] So sometimes
those exploratory classes,
of I may be interested in this
and I just want to put my toe in the pool
and see if I like the
water, is a valuable thing.
We want to give them flexibility.
- You can basically do whatever you want.
I'm taking a Psychology class and
I'm taking a Theology class this semester.
- These classes are
straight college credit.
They would transfer just like anybody
who went to a university
their freshman year
and decided to switch universities.
Some of the courses,
for example English 101,
we would also credit them with
a senior English credit here.
So, you have nine hours of
elective transfer credit,
and then you've already
got 27 of the 39 hours.
So you're really close.
- [Jared] It actually shocked me, because
I'm going to have a lot of
the credits out of the way.
- Where I'd be going to
school for neuroscience,
it would be for five years.
Instead, now it's going
to be for four years.
So that's even better, because
it gets me into med school quicker
and I can go ahead and
start what I want to do.
- For a lot of these kids,
they're leaving high school
with more hours than somebody
in the family has ever earned.
And so, it's really that proof
before they move away and are on their own
that they can do it and they can succeed.
- The Bellarmine program has
taught me that I can do this,
like I can finish college,
I will finish college.
And it just makes me really
excited for the future.
- I'm very proud of you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You've done very...